watching this last night reminded me why
I will never go in the ocean shut it's a
weighted statement there is no reason
there's nothing good in there that can
come out making something like this
though does it actually like tweak you a
little bit realizing like when you're
for example when you're doing swimming
scenes are you constantly a little bit
more in your head yeah so he shot some
scenes in the open ocean in the
Dominican Republic and that was really
scary because you're pretending that
you're running away from a shark but
you're actually afraid that there's a
shark somewhere so we're having these
divers under there like looking around
for sharks but I don't trust anybody the
whole time right and by the way you're
right to be thinking that right yes
hundred percent oh yeah like never
absolutely um so when you're getting
ready I'm curious how quickly were you
guys cast and then filming the process
was long for me I think you know I tried
out for all all the girls and then I
didn't hear anything for two weeks I met
the director didn't hear anything if you
don't call back in didn't hear so that
one dragged up it was worth every second
of panic I mean I auditioned and then a
couple days after I got it and I think a
month after I
they had already casted my role and then
I think the girl fell out I don't really
know what happened to her actually or
who it was but they called me on like a
Thursday and they were like we need you
to come down and I got on a plane on
Sunday and was in the Dominican filming
so it was very quick for me I was gonna
say I'm very curious because something
sometimes when you get cast it can be
like you're shooting in six months or a
year it's like what you just said yeah
it's like oh can you come tomorrow
you're already in the Dominican yeah we
were there we're like Halon he goes oh
yeah she's coming down look okay great
like a week before shooting right have
we cast some force are you getting ready
to go film you're getting ready to do
this project what are you doing to
prepare because it does seem like this
is like a physical role you know yeah we
so definitely do dive training of course
because I know I fibbed about saying
that I was licensed yeah good thing I
was gonna get it so yeah we had we they
definitely prepared us and we each had
our own dive instructor so it was very
hands-on experience the whole time and
they made us feel as comfortable as
possible you guys I mean same we all had
to do the same yeah
diving process it was fun yeah I knew
how to swim before so she didn't I
didn't know how to swim before so yeah
that was part of the lack of training I
had but when I got there I had to figure
it out and we did a few days of training
and I can say I can swim now after
filming this so you're getting ready to
film the movie what's the day you're
looking at the script you know what's
coming what's the day that you're most
excited to film and what's the day you
are absolutely scared shitless
I was really excited you all there like
the cheap stuff cuz I knew holy life
fire is really filming we it was the
most fun scene - it's all of us energy
coming out being girls and like it was
the first day and I was shaking I go
okay the way I jump out of this car it
needs to be perfect and the first take I
slip mud I was just nervous cause it's
my first take on camera ever doing I was
really nervous for the we take our masks
off at some point and we have to free
dive and hold our breaths and so I was
dreading this because it was a huge
stunt but it was also very real and the
fact that we're underwater
we don't have masks on anymore and we
have to hold our breath and hope and
pray that somebody's gonna give us air
would we need it
so that was something I was really
afraid okay yeah and we rehearsed all
this stuff in like this tank where the
water was really clear and you could see
everything and you you knew where your
diver was and when we got on the day
they put us under this submarine in the
ocean when you can't see anything our
eyes were burning and they changed our
divers I was I was freaking out - you're
saying that making movies is not super
glamorous all the time glamorous part of
so I have what we call a few fun
questions we'll find out if they're fun
in about two minutes what TV show would
you love to guest star on euphoria oh so
big right now I thank you for you I've
always been a fan of Gossip Girl I don't
know maybe like forever Dale okay what
movie have you seen the most prisoners I
saw it 12 times
I saw cruel it I've seen cruel
intentions a hundred times prisoners is
quite good there it is and Jake
Gyllenhaal and yes it's kind of good I
just throw that out there what TV show
have you seen all the way through more
than once
probably Parks and Rec let's go good
these are all good selections a favorite
ride at Disneyland my favorite right at
Disneyland oh it the Matterhorn Oh like
Pirates of the Caribbean do the game no
these are all still valid is there
anything that you collect I used to
collect the server's like quarters
because you know how they all have
different states on them
sure so I used to have like a little mat
that I would put on the court anyways
and this was when you were five yeah
more I should have actually said it was
last week anyway
um I don't know if you can really say
collect but I'm a huge fan of like
Polaroids like fan of like polarize and
I just have like my room is filled with
like yeah well I think of quarters yeah
I collect like um felt like old film
cameras and like old like art books so
like a lot of coffee table books
what was the last thing you were super
obsessed with whether it be like a movie
it could be anything I'm really into
like we were just talking about like
astrology and like signs and like your
rising sign your moons that like I'm all
into that I find this from a lot of
people recently rising sign and all that
side you got to know it all
you're not just one thing so I think I'm
in it I probably know where my friends
and my boyfriend to death I've been
watching this one show Barry Oh Barry
I mean but it's that one every time I'm
sitting on my bed I watched another I've
said and I'm gone through like two
seasons already in two days yeah it's so
good I don't know I'm obsessed with food
all the time every day oh yeah you had
Ben and Jerry's on side oh I had Ben and
Jerry's and then I did I did free shoots
like three months later I had to go back
into a couple of scenes and my Ben &
Jerry's was still there in the freezer
three months later and I ate it speaking
of you know a little bit of a scary
movies here what films scared you as a
kid or maybe what film did you see a
little shy on it oh my green to this day
I have the in my room and I'll look in
the corner and I swear see a little girl
like coming walking like the ring messed
me yeah that's by the time I say mine
was sinister like that face i I couldn't
every time I look into a mirror I was
all it nighttime freaks me out
Coraline oh I'm gonna say
congratulations on the movie thank you
mostly because again it reminds me why
I'm never getting in the ocean yeah and
you don't have to we did it for you
I'm done yeah I'm retired